[موسيقى]
المنتخب المغربي الرابع والعالم ملكه جمال
كرواتيا تنافس لاعبي المنتخب عوده صديق
وميسي القديم قبل النهائي هذا الاخبار
وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه رياضه اهلا
بكم
بعدين رحله المميزه في كاس العالم انتهى
مشوار المنتخب المغربي باحتلاله المركز
الرابع في البطوله بعد خسارته امام
كرواتيا بهدفين مقابل هدف واحد ويبقى هذا
الانجاز هو الافضل في تاريخ المنتخبات
الافريقيه والعربيه ومن المنتظر ان يحظى
اسود الاطلس باستقبل لدى عودتهم الى
المغرب غدا الاحد
ملكه جمال كرواتيا بعد شهرتها خلال كاس
العالم المنتخب الكرواتي وبلغ عدد متابعها
مع قرب انتهاء المونديال اكثر من ثلاثه
ملايين متابع وهو ما يعادل عدد سكان
كرواتيا كما تزايد عدد متابعي ايفانا خلال
ايام كاس العالم بنحو 200 الف متابع كل
يوم على موقع انستغرام
الجميع
خلال المباراه النهائيه كما اشارت بعض
التقارير الاعلاميه الى ان اغويرو ميسي
قبل النهائي مثل ما جرت العاده ولا
السنوات التي
مع المنتخب الارجنتيني
[موسيقى]
في خبرنا الاخير اقتحمت جماهير مباراه
ديربي ميلبور في الدوري الاسترالي ملعب
المباراه بعد مرور 21 دقيقه في اللقاء
الذي جمع
فيكتوري وهجمت الجماهير حارس ميلبور سيتي
كمحطمت اللوحات الاعلانيه وترى الحكم بكل
تاكيد الى الغاء المباراه
[موسيقى]